um you've been saying a lot about how
again how light all these people are
thinking that they're bringing them food
for you as a white male have you ever
tried putting yourself in these people
shoes or try to look from there as
family children I mean this but I don't
know what that means because every
individual has a different standpoint :
Powell's kid is not the fellow just
spoke you know this idea that did the
idea that you should that you know
everyone when we say put yourself in
somebody else's shoes there's actually a
fascinating study about this has empathy
is bad politics sympathy is good
politics empathy is bad politics what I
mean is I've never looked at the world
through their live you know what I plan
to be a or why rejuvenated okay
so as far as discrimination I don't
claim victimhood status even though I
was the number one target of
anti-semitism on the internet last year
okay I'm not discriminated against in
the United States and very free here I
do really well as far as the idea that
the best way to do politics or the best
way to make public policy or the best
way to discuss politics in public is to
walk in someone else's shoes see through
somebody else's eyes that's true at a
very rudimentary level you try to
understand somebody's problems but the
idea that that is the basis for public
policy in law they tasting that there's
a phrase in law it's called hard cases
make bad law right the idea is that if
you have too much sympathy for the
person who's in front of you you end up
making bad overall decisions and there
been Studies on this about empathy and
politics empathy actually leads to bad
policy because your empathize while
you're empathizing for the person whose
shoes you're standing in you're
forgetting about the effects of the
public policy you're recommending on the
other million people the public policy
actually impact and so you know if the
implication is that my perspective is
coming from a lack of empathy or a lack
of sympathy I utterly disagree I think
that my perspective is coming from the
ultimate sympathy which I want to see
people succeed in the society and the
way to make people fail in the society
is by inculcating in them from the time
they're 5 but they are destined to fail
in a society discriminates against them